[Music]
[Music]
control is this constellation starship
frontier
we're ready to start on your signal
[Music]
maintaining exit vector course steady
till ready
coordinates input plotting jump
course has converged
we're looking good
one
[Music]
it's hard to express how excited all of
us at bethesda are to be here with you
today we're so grateful you're spending
the time and we know you've waited a
long time to finally see
starfield it's easily our most ambitious
game ever like our previous games it's
an epic role-playing game where you get
to be who you want and go where you want
but this time you'll be exploring space
so let's jump right in this is early in
the game as you arrive on the mysterious
moon of crete
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
according to the scanners the abandoned
research facility is in this direction
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
it would appear that pirates of the
crimson fleet are using the facility
we've got company
you're gonna pay for that
after some initial encounters you're
invited to join constellation who in the
future the game is set in are the last
group of space explorers to meet them
you'll head to the capital city of new
atlantis
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to constellation we have a lot
to talk about
we're all here because we're committed
to the biggest question of all
what's
out there
these artifacts could be everything
we've been looking for
as to what they are
what they're building
you'll be part of solving that puzzle
now
so you found something the new guy found
it
you dug up the artifact right that means
you saw it the visions
the artifact you found appears to be one
of many scattered across the galaxy
if we can find more we can unlock the
secrets beautiful isn't it the man who
sold me this told me that it spoke to
him of course the settle systems is full
of groups with other priorities
that's the crimson fleet everybody get
ready the fleet doesn't follow the rules
agree to work for uc system together we
take down this cutthroat pirates
we're not just here to shoot the bad
guys we're peacekeepers who protect the
people of the freestar collective
when you sign up with a crimson fleet
no one quits the only way
is death
the path ahead may be dangerous
but we are not stopping
most dusties don't even make it this far
because whatever lies at the end of this
road
will change humanity
forever
that gives you a look at the stories in
starfield but ultimately it's not our
story it's the story you create by who
you are and the choices you make and
that starts with character creation
[Music]
it's our most flexible yet
you can customize all the elements of
how you look
[Music]
you'll pick a background that gives you
three starting skills
[Music]
says here you spend some time as a
diplomat having a way with words might
prove useful
there are optional traits and these come
with unique advantages and disadvantages
but it's not just in how you can look
and how your character plays and
develops
[Music]
the skill system combines the best from
our previous games
and you can unlock new skills as you
level up and then you rank those skills
up by using them and completing
challenges
and there's deep crafting systems from
running research projects with resources
you find
to crafting weapon mods needed to
survive
[Music]
and you can build your own outposts
these act as a home away from home for
survival and resource generation
you can choose where and how to build
each one
and you can hire characters you meet to
keep it up and running
but
that's not all
[Music]
you can even build your own spaceships
[Music]
you can choose crew members
and yes you can completely customize the
look and layout
there's loads of different modules ship
manufacturers and more
i have to say it's so cool we just
absolutely love this
[Music]
it's not just how the ship looks it's
how it performs from engines to shields
to weapon systems
because yes
you can fly it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we can't wait for all of you to
experience the game thanks again for
being with us today and thanks for all
the support you've given us over the
decades especially on this game it's
been an incredible journey for us making
it but we know
that's really only the beginning for
it's when all of you play it that the
real journey begins
and you may be wondering just how big is
this game
so we thought we'd take one last moment
and show you
let's take a look at one of our planets
jemisin
you can land in new atlantis
but you can also land and explore
anywhere on the planet
and it's not just this planet
it's all the planets in the system
from barren but resource heavy ice balls
to goldilocks planets with life
and not just this system
but over a hundred systems
over 1 000 planets
all open for you to explore
we can't wait
to see what you find
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i found you
bearer of the internal elixir field
okay
play it day one with game pass
[Music]
then you can call me
[Music]
that's right
[Music]
i
[Music]
i'm
forza motorsport is back i'm dan
greenwald gm of motorsport and i'm
joined by chris asaki creative director
at turn 10.
forza is known for its photo reel beauty
and state of the art immersion
built from the ground up to showcase the
xbox series x and s consoles
including techniques like real-time ray
tracing on track this is the most
technically advanced racing game ever
made
today
we're excited to show you the all-new
forza motorsport
welcome to maple valley
this track has been a fan favorite since
the original motorsport launched back in
2005.
for the first time in forza motorsport
fully dynamic time of day brings maple
valley to life in stunning detail
what you are seeing is an in-engine
gameplay demo presented using a single
camera with no cuts
let's jump in with the m8
we've completely overhauled the driving
experience
this includes a 48 times improvement in
the fidelity of our physics simulation
advance time of day here and look at the
world details
everything you see is new and has been
captured with photogrammetry and 3d
material scans advanced rendering and
procedural generation techniques bring a
new level of realism to the track
here you can see the beautiful fall
colors of maple valley
the grass
rocks 3d vegetation skies and clouds
they all demonstrate a generational leap
in beauty and detail
let's advance time again
you are looking at our all-new dynamic
time of day
this is a fundamental system to the new
forza motorsport
and like weather is available on every
track
these new simulation details add further
depth drama and dynamics to the racing
experience
in addition to our dynamic time of day
forward plus lighting and physically
based lights come together to deepen the
realism and immersion in the world
changes in the time of day also change
ambient temperatures which affect track
surface temps
grip is also affected by these track
temp changes
rubbering in and of course weather
let's head to the pits
we've added features that players have
been asking for
tire and fuel management
multiple tire compounds and new depth in
car building create the ultimate racing
playset
advanced materials and shaders paired
with ray tracing bring out incredible
detail in the gold heat wrap anodized
aluminum and carbon fiber
engine bays with their complex
self-reflection is a place where ray
tracing
really shines
car damage is a racing reality
in forza motorsport
car damage is reproduced down to the
individual scratches on the bodywork
you can see here some of the new details
in the directionality of damage how the
paint peels away at exposed and raised
edges
in the wheel abrasions
and even in the dirt buildup
using the power of the xbox series x and
s consoles
ray tracing makes everything feel more
connected
cars reflecting onto other cars
cars reflect in their own mirrors body
work brake rotors and wings
things just feel more natural
more real
we believe that the accuracy of our
overhaul physics
the beauty of our cars and tracks
our new dynamic time of day
advanced car damage and real time rate
tracing on track
lead to a generational leap in immersion
this
is the all-new forza motorsport
[Music]
hey
oh
[Music]
hmm
what
[Music]
i speak now
to those who heed a darker coal
those bold enough to cross the line of
sin
for deeper knowledge
who follow an unquenchable
yearning
[Music]
born blood and bone
[Music]
to unlock
the forbidden secrets and foulest black
rituals
calling for life
from death
[Music]
[Music]
to truly embrace this power
you must take it into the world
and you will be shunned
scorned
marked as a living sacrifice
to this profane knowledge
[Music]
you will be a priest of rathma
[Music]
a necromancer
and you will not confront the darkness
alone
we are the speakers of the dead
and the dead
have no
mercy
[Music]
diablo 4 is the next generation of
action rpg
melding monster slaying and loot
collecting with a fully realized open
world
it's not for the faint of heart
it's gory and
unnerving
it's creepy
diablo 4 is all about player choice
it takes all of the pillars of the
diablo game and just expands them
with all the new features that people
really love and appreciate in modern
games
whoever you see yourself being you can
create in diablo for
it's important to include robust
character customization because then i
can play the fantasy that i want to play
[Applause]
it allows you to
switch around your playstyle as well
everything feels very powerful and fun
one of the really cool things about
having an open world is your journey
that you take throughout diablo 4 is
your own
there's no linear path that you have to
follow
we've got almost 150 dungeons in the
game
there's all kinds of surprises as you're
exploring
strongholds are an enemy territory that
you need to reclaim
you might have a space that begins as a
hostile area
but after you've cleared it out the evil
in this place has been cleansed it now
becomes a friendly town
sometimes it's a new town sometimes it's
a new dungeon
there's a whole bunch of rewards that
you get and you have a real impact on
the world as a result
no you can't leave us here they might
come back any moment local events are
really cool little story segments that
happen within the open world we'll just
be running through the world and then a
local event will pop up and you can
choose to participate in it
or get a group together and just wail on
these like giant world bosses
these are events that take a lot of
people and you really have to work
together
being able to see all the players on
your screen collaborating trying to take
this big monster down it's it's epic
it's so easy to create a community it
makes diablo more of a social experience
we've got fully enabled cross play
if you have an xbox and your buddy has a
pc you're going to be able to group up
or you can play couch co-op two people
on a couch can sit there and have a
great experience
we've created specific zones where
players can engage in pvp
if you go there you can start swinging
away at people
but you're also opening yourself up to
being swung at
if you're like really really good the
game actually marks you as like a
champion on the map
you basically become a loot pinata and
everyone wants to chase you down
the last story mission is really the
beginning of a whole different part of
the journey
now you're set up for the end game and
that end game is rich with things to do
that allow you to get more and more
powerful whether it's new items or new
dungeons or new paragon boards every
single time you come back to play diablo
4 there's going to be new stuff for you
to experience
and it's something we're going to
support for years to come
i'm really excited for folks to get
their hands on diablo 4.
just to see millions of people really
enjoying the different options through
the campaign local events couch co-op or
end game pvp
it almost doesn't end
and we are so close
[Music]
i'm sorry amicia
for hugo
he's not dead yet
[Music]
[Music]
the macula's not just in hugo's blood it
concerns everybody
and it can change everything
from the flesh
[Music]
remember no more killing soldiers no
more killing us
look out there's a killer around here
one of our men has been murdered
[Music]
you're only making it worse
unless you
[Music]
don't i'm tired of being afraid i'll
show them that it's over finally
see they're nothing nothing to be scared
of
[Music]
you are not them what is wrong with me
[Music]
my dad tells stories of a terrible war
that happened across the sky
heroes fought
and died to give us a chance to start
over
[Applause]
all that i know from their earth are the
creatures they sent along with us
and here on iraq every day is a fight to
survive
[Music]
but if anyone can tame this new world
we can
[Music]
which one's your favorite
mine's tracer
she's like she's not the cavalry's here
you're one of those heroes aren't you
before me i see the future
human
machine
you know there's more out there don't
you
even the best journeys end
but a new one
is right around the corner
[Music]
i am your queen
let's take him to the wasteland
one punch is all i need
[Music]
nice work team
keep it moving
i cannot wait
[Music]
get in there
it takes a team to tango
[Music]
[Music]
i will
[Music]
i
left my face
[Music]
break away
[Music]
one day
[Music]
now we know that love will change
[Music]
[Music]
rumor has it something's off at the
church
there's blood in the baptismal font and
pastor's gone missing
and my genius plan was to investigate it
alone
[Music]
of course
don't stress layla
oh [ __ ]
ugh
oh
oh [ __ ] there's more
kiss your ass goodbye
jacob oh thank god come on let's find
the others and beat feet
and these aren't just trashy movie
vampires these monsters blocked out the
sun and pushed back all the water
totally cut us off from the outside
world
gotta admit though if i have to be stuck
on an island full of vampires i'm glad
it's with y'all feelings mutual i guess
oh thanks jacob
we've also got remy our engineer genius
and her little robot buddy
who's a good robot who's the best robot
and our resident experts on all things
creepy i prefer the term cryptozoologist
but to reach their own last but not
least yours truly i have these weird
powers
we've been digging for answers but
haven't found much beyond blood and
death luckily the vampires and their
sycophants aren't discreet about where
they like to nest i'd bet the answers we
need are inside those tourist traps
turned fortresses
spotted some bloodsuckers in their fan
club near the festival grounds let's
start there
ghosting out
[Music]
cultists could go straight at them or
just slip past let's just get this done
on my mark
oh [ __ ] bloodbag
i know we're here look alive
this one is mine going up
my cryptid hunter's intuition tells me
there's a nest nearby you're what duff
that's not a thing
found something oh now i simply must go
in there what is that
where does it go
some kind of collective consciousness
that's impossible
there's the movie theater i used to come
here all the time why'd they have to
mess this up for me
it'll
oh
any second run
[Music]
you